[Music]
oscar-winner Morgan Freeman is nearly
100 movie credits show off including
attention Driving Miss Daisy and
Invictus he's also an executive producer
of the hit CBS drama Madam Secretary
Freeman directed the season 4 premiere
and in this preview he reprises his role
as Supreme Court Chief Justice will bore
Chief Justice I don't think I've ever
seen you in here before I'm not much of
a power breakfast type not that there's
anything wrong with that it's just done
more of a muffin on the fly type there's
just somebody I needed to bump into yes
there is and I wouldn't want to be
senator Morra home right now Morgan
Freeman has come back to the table
welcome sir thank you very much ok so
here you are director executive producer
and actor and this is you're not new to
the director's chair you're preparing
for a third chapter in life yes yes
acting is losing its sting it's zip for
me Morgan
well early on they're getting all the
look good character roles people go to
see the character and then somewhere
along the way you become a star and now
it's all about you not just the fact
that you are there and instead of how do
people want to be stars oh well no we
all walk stars yeah it's you know that's
where the money is that's where they any
good roles and then good roles yep fames
is great but it's a two-edged sword you
know the gay rights to go ahead sir I
love the right thing yes we do what is
it love hmm what is it you love about it
the whole concept of being in control of
a presentation particularly a movie or
for a show where are you dealing with
and crew yeah crew in particular like
the work is done
yeah you mean your cinematographer and
everybody else yeah yeah the work gets
done behind the scenes yeah so and and I
like pasting them up in shaping the
script yes all of that and that's not a
collaborative thing with an actor hat yo
and you know exactly what the actors are
going through - I think they'd give them
a benefit you have to and you know if
they have a question me and my venerable
miss voice of God yeah but if somebody
walks in with a great of great role
you're going to always accept it aren't
you yes of course yes let me ask you
though television is an ongoing story
unlike movies right I mean it unfolds
over seasons yes
with something like Madam Secretary we
know that Hillary Clinton for example
watches the show she's a former
Secretary of State are you thinking
about your audience and in a way we
don't all right all right she's really a
big fan of the show do you or do you
think about those people watching your
product when you're shooting it no no
not at all about it no I don't think
about who might be watching just is
everybody satisfied with what they're
getting what you're doing and it's great
sometimes just to say to an actor know
the direction that you give to Te'o
Leone I'm curious what kind of dirt you
said that to tear it up a little bit
yeah you're not working oh they just
love having that input
everybody says thank you also they know
that you know what you're talking about
right it gives you what it yeah I think
it's possible when you're doing a series
Oh
know that the energy level - it goes
long just say energy when you're not
working where are you and what are you
doing but I'm not working I'm at home I
have in Mississippi in Mississippi I
live in this little very very small town
that I lived in when I'm a little boy
didn't grow up in this town but they
must love having you there
well Mississippi loves having me but
you're also working with you have a
documentary the story of us yes which is
Alex pointed out during a break is
something that seems to be needed at
this time tell us a little bit about
that it's about you find the humanity of
people yeah it's the story of us as just
as people today went all over the place
doing it and talking to leaders of
countries talking to people who have had
extraordinary experiences in life that
gave them some insight to the reality of
things to read them for instance talk to
a lot of people about the idea of
freedom one young man who was born and
raised in North Korea in a prison camp
you didn't know anything like that until
he was 26 years old well it's very
encouraging to hear because whenever I
get worried about the world to hear you
and Charlie say we're gonna be fine
no we are we're going to be the girls
gonna be fine Thank You Morgan Freeman
always a pleasure always
you can watch the season 4 premiere of
Madame secretary this Sunday night